rappel obligation de se faire vacciner
c'est pour l'instant réservé à certains
ou certaines professions en France comme
les soignants les pompiers où les
travailleurs au contact de personnes
âgées alors pour endiguer cette 5e vague
qui fait peur faut-il aller plus loin à
la France devrait-elle étendre
l'obligation vaccinale à toute la
population on attend toujours sur le
compte telegram verte et France et c'est
l'heure de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en parler j'accueille ce soir
pour te plaît trop Patrick Mennucci
Bonsoir Patrick Mennucci membres du PS
ancien député des Bouches-du-Rhône merci
d'être là à vos côtés en face à la
Capelle député européen du rassemblement
national Bonsoir j'en ai à la Capelle la
situation est pas terrible en 50000
nouvelles continue le mination en 24
heures plus de 32000 km par jour en
moyenne sur les 7 jours 13 cas officiel
un Patrick Mennucci
sur le micro il pourrait y en avoir plus
on en parle un petit peu cette émission
la France quand même qui sévit niveau
des frontières all entendu avec notre
reporter ça va plus être évident de
circuler entre l'Afrique australe et la
France et surtout désormais les
voyageurs de présenter des tests que
c'est un négative de moins de 48 heures
avant la rentrée en France y compris
quand ils font vacciner il était temps
vous allez me dire
oui alors là on est à l'opération de
communication s'il a fallu au moins je
souhaite je crois que c'est une bonne
chose décès de réguler
nos frontières de manière à ce que la
propagation des frontières ne le
supprime pas
permet de freiner la propagation du
virus
parfois je le reconnais sur notamment
sur les frontières dans les mots je le
reconnais une bonne intention je
voudrais seulement que derrière
il faut faire
il faut changer ça
tous les trois sourire
il
y a 2 question qui se pose
la question de la vaccination des pays
émergents et les pays pauvres et
derrière dans la vaccination mondiale
réalité et la vaccination obligatoire
des Européens et
depuis quelques mois puisque le groupe
socialiste
exprimer cette position à l'Assemblée
nationale et c'est la position de notre
formation politique est-ce que je crois
qu'il est qui est qui est
le député européen on va pas aller
critiquer parce que
pays d'Afrique australe de rencontrer
seule de
l'agrément les voyages professionnel ça
me paraît frapper au coin du bon sens et
la question c'est que tout ça ce sont
des éléments
partiels et qui répondent à une
situation d'urgence je pense qu'il
serait vraiment très important que le G7
ou le G20
fasse des actes km
internationaux très précis pour
s'assurer que les milliards d'individus
qui vivent cette planète et accès à la
vaccination parce que sinon on voit bien
que les frontières sont quand même
temps on peut
parler de frontière quand on parle de
migration ou de contrôle douanier
et que on a
une
pour limiter c'est ce qu'il faut c'est
que tout le monde se vacciner et
je crois que vous allez en parler mais
je pense que c'est très important même
si ça pose des questions de liberté même
si ça pose des questions
d'explication je crois qu'on devrait
obligé tous les Français sont vaccinés
on va rentrer dans le débat puisque
le grand débat quand est apparu ce virus
contre connais pas encore bien en
Afrique du Sud on a pas assez fait pour
quand on voit que tu as in distribuer de
dose en Afrique des descentes de
vaccination et pour nous
c'est vrai que le rendement est un peu
plus modeste vous ça vous inspire toi en
tant que député européen seulement vous
pousser pour davantage en Afrique et
qu'on arrête ans il est peut-être
davantage les virus sur le territoire
dans cette situation
tu es un peu la risée du monde nous on
européenne pensant que nous serions
meilleur que les autres et pourtant que
la clé d'entrée de cette négociation
Parlement européen devait être le prix
alors que on est en guerre c'est pas le
prix ce qu'il faut c'est le plus vite
possible et pouvoir ensuite mettre à
disposition des gens qui fait cette
d'activer le vaccin et nous avons pris
les choses à l'inverse d'acheter le
moins cher moins cher
donc on a commis une erreur je crois
avec des gens qui d'ailleurs pas de
sortant à négocier de manière équilibrée
qui défend les intérêts
il vous faut un pas sanitaire pouvoir se
passe sanitaire il nous faut finalement
être vacciné puisque si vous souhaitez
ne pas être vacciné on l'était si vous
l'avez compris la gratuité vient de
décider quelques semaines la réduction
du délai de validité des testes a été de
24 heures tout cela pour pousser les
gens donc c'est une obligation vaccinale
et qu'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est impossible de solidarité extérieur
non je le crois pas je lui il y a pas de
solidarité la belle ça fait ah c'est
même pas des bons sentiments je pense
que la vaccination mondiale c'est un
principe de survie pour chacun d'entre
nous donc il faut il faut retourner la
question n'est pas là pour dire d'abord
ce qui se passe dans les autres on
appelle à une
prise de conscience mondial
international de vaccination
je pourrai pas venir
[Musique]
problème sur les vaccins obligatoires
moi jeune dans
la question de la conviction j'ai
discuté avec Anne Hidalgo hier
pour se caler sur ce sujet
[Musique]
mais
on est bien obligé
vous et moi nous sommes
la moment que nous parlons et j'ai
regardé le carnet de santé de mon fils
avec cette affaire là c'est
une question
écouter aussi François Bayrou qui défend
également comme vous Patrick Mennucci la
vaccination obligatoire écouter
le jour viendra où la vaccination
obligatoire s'imposera je dis ça depuis
le mois de janvier à l'époque on
craignait que le vaccin et des effets
secondaires il y avait des gens qui
disait ça va être une hécatombe encore
on s'aperçoit aujourd'hui que c'est
absolument faux
il dit on a suffisamment de
moi que moi d'ailleurs moi je me permets
pas de parler à la place de qui on a pas
le recul que l'on avait sur celui-là
aujourd'hui
et
[Musique]
il va continuer 12 personnes et
quelqu'un qui a comme nous à l'instant
aujourd'hui le plus dangereux
aujourd'hui
il
ne tient pas ses promesses
parce que je crois qu'ils mettent en
danger il y a bien deux avant je voulais
vous faire écouter mais vous avez un peu
tu dis
si les États reste souvent c'est vrai
que j'aurai avec elle l'a dit l'Autriche
qui est mise l'Allemagne se pose la
question est-ce que on ne va pas y
couper en France je pense qu'on va y
arriver moi ce que je fais
je moi je suis pas le représentant
et je
pense qu'il faut
[Musique]
et
je vois pas
en janvier nous expliquer que il y avait
des gens qui avait attrapé pour la
Réunion plus les lacets j'ai ouvert tous
à vos amis qui peuvent soutenir
aujourd'hui
et
[Musique]
que vous
allez
pas de la même façon regarder l'écart
entre le nombre de gens qui sont
déclarées positif au covit est la
situation des hôpitaux n'est pas la même
que celle qu'elle était mais je pense
que là il y a un mois je fais appel à la
à l'intelligence de tous ceux qui sont
en situation de décider quel que soit
l'endroit où il le somme on n'est pas
dans une affaire idéologique on est dans
la survie de la nation
il y a 20 enfants qui sont morts de
moins de 19 ans donc enfants et
adolescents 20
personnes aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
deuxièmement on est en manque de l'huile
de vidéo depuis 20 ans supprimer et en
2020 le gouvernement a eu le culot de
supprimer 5700 lits en plein
absolument
problème et parce qu'on a pas
aujourd'hui
moi je pense que c'est très important
que les enfants puissent vaccinés et
bien merci à vous deux Patrick Mennucci